digamos que tenemos dos matrices y por
facilidad empezaré con dos matrices de
dos por dos
esta primera será de dos menos dos
5 y picamos
digamos 3 y tendremos esta de aquí
también de 2 x 2
que será menos 1
4 y digamos 7 y menos 6 y lo que quiero
en este vídeo lo que les quiero mostrar
es la convención la convención
matemática para multiplicar dos matrices
como estas y quiero resaltar eso porque
los matemáticos pudieron haber creado
múltiples maneras para definir la
multiplicación de matrices pero la
convención que les voy a mostrar es la
manera en que se hace y se hace de esta
manera y especialmente cuando estén en
clases de álgebra lineal más avanzadas o
empiecen a hacer gráficos de computadora
o hasta cuando movele en diferentes
tipos de fenómenos verán porque esta
manera de multiplicar matriz es la que
estoy a punto de mostrarles es la que
más se aplica
pero quiero resaltar esta es una
convención creada por humanos los
humanos se dieron cuenta que la manera
de multiplicar matrices con el método
que les voy a mostrar resultaba muy útil
y pensamos en cómo en cómo podría hacer
esto una vez más quiero resaltar que es
una convención humana hay muchas maneras
en las que se pudo haber pensado
multiplicar matrices de 2 por 2 lo
pudiste haber hecho de la misma manera
en que se suman las matrices cuando
sumas matrices las dos matrices deben de
tener la misma dimensión y solo suman
los términos correspondientes de las
matrices entonces una manera pudo haber
sido para el producto de aquí porque no
porque no sólo multiplicamos los
términos correspondientes
y termino pudo haber sido 2 x menos 1 y
ponemos el menos 2 aquí otro menos 2 x
menos 4 y ponemos el menos 8 aquí así es
como hacemos la suma sumamos los
términos correspondientes pero esa no es
la convención para multiplicar matrices
no es la convención estándar
la convención estándar para multiplicar
matrices es para obtener el término de
aquí el de arriba a la izquierda vamos a
utilizar el producto de esta fila de
esta fila
con esta columna esta columna de aquí
y qué es lo que significa obtener el
producto de una fila por una columna si
están familiarizados con el producto
punto en vectores esto les puede sonar
familiar multiplicamos a los términos
correspondientes el producto de los
primeros términos y el producto de los
segundos términos y después los sumamos
esto es esencialmente lo que haremos
vamos a hacer el producto punto de la
primera fila con la primera columna y
eso nos va a dar el primer término de
arriba izquierda que va exactamente aquí
si el decir producto punto no tiene
ningún sentido para ustedes les voy a
mostrar lo que significa entonces
déjenme déjenme de hecho dejen de
deshacerme de esto de aquí creo que será
útil en especial en esta que es la
primera vez que intentamos multiplicar
matrices
entonces el término de aquí arriba a la
izquierda será 2 x menos 1 entonces 2 x
- 1
+ - 2
- 2
por 7
+ 2 por 7 y no está primero tome el
producto del primer término de la fila
con el primer término de la columna y
después el producto del segundo término
de la fila y el segundo término de la
columna que está aquí y después los voy
a sumar lo que es esencialmente hacer el
producto punto de este vector fila con
este vector columna si no tiene sentido
esto si no estás familiarizado con los
vectores de los productos punto no te
preocupes simplemente hicimos el
producto de los primeros términos y el
producto de los segundos términos y los
humanos esto nos va a dar un valor y lo
vamos a calcular en unos segundos pero
ahora pensemos en los otros entonces
para obtener este
termino de aquí vamos a tomar a la
primera fila de esta matriz y la segunda
columna de de esta matriz y esto tiene
sentido porque seguimos en la primera
fila pero en la segunda columna de la
primera fila
primera fila segunda columna entonces
será 2 por 4 2 por 4 más
menos dos más menos 2 por menos
y en este punto los invito a pausar el
vídeo y utilizando lo que ya vieron vean
si pueden completar esto intenten ver si
logran obtener el término de abajo a la
izquierda y el término de abajo a la
derecha les daré una pista tiene algo
que ver con esta segunda fila de aquí
entonces asumiendo que ya lo intentaron
por su cuenta vamos a trabajar el
ejercicio juntos a veces las
multiplicaciones de matrices se pueden
poner un poco intensas
y ahora estamos en la segunda fila
estamos en la segunda fila de esta
primera matriz y para este término será
la segunda fila y la primera columna
segunda fila y primer columna 5 x menos
15 x menos uno más tres por siete más
tres por siete
y finalmente ya estamos en lo último
para obtener este para obtener este este
término inferior derecho multiplicamos
esta fila esencialmente por esta columna
de aquí y entonces será 5 x 4
5 x 43 x menos 6 + 3 x menos 6 ahora
cuánto sería todo esto simplificado esto
sería igual a veamos entonces menos 2
más
menos 14 esto será menos 16 este de aquí
es menos 16 y ahora tenemos 8 12
esto será 20 y ahora tenemos menos 5 más
21 lo que será 16 16 positivo lo hice
bien si 16 positivo y finalmente tenemos
20 menos 18
eso será 2 entonces el producto de estas
dos matrices merecemos un poco de
suspenso aquí cuando multiplicamos esta
matriz de 2 por 2 por esta otra matriz
de dos por dos vamos a obtener
vamos a obtener menos 16
y acabamos